if you grew up playing video games like
I did
you've probably heard lots of
conflicting information some save too
much gaming will ruin your vision and
rot your brain while others claim it
improves your hand-eye coordination and
can even make you smarter so what
exactly does gaming do to our brain and
our body to find out I visited doctors
and researchers were seeing brain
activity and different frequencies
tested my hand-eye coordination against
a pro-gamer you can't catch up somehow
ended up in a sub 200 degree cryo
chamber I'll to answer the question how
do video games affect us the stakes are
higher than ever the industry is booming
these sports have gone mainstream there
are college leagues parents are even
getting video game tutors for their kids
and thanks in part to smartphones and
free games like fortnight gamers are
playing more than ever before so given
that we can play virtually anywhere at
any time how is all this gaming changing
us physically let's start with the
excuse I used to give my mom when I was
trying to get a little bit more time on
the Atari it's making me a better
athlete to find out if that's actually
true I headed to the Sports Academy in
Thousand Oaks California for amateur
gamers and eSports pros trained under
the same roof as traditional athletes
this is pro gamer Matt Higginbotham I'm
known online as a KD in between training
and casual gaming Matt please 8 to 10
hours a day people say you know it
improves hand-eye coordination it
improves response time kind of what have
you seen in your own life if you only
play League of Legends that's like your
only activity with no physical exercise
in my opinion you're just gonna get out
of shape in terms of positives yeah
maybe it may be cognitive it would
increase the things you're gonna use in
the game we actually do things quickly
making decisions quickly
so is he right let's find out if being
an avid gamer actually makes you sharper
we're gonna be taking a bunch of
cognitive tests one after the other now
Matt is a pro gamer I am very much not
so we're gonna see exactly how our
results break down the first test is my
new arch nemesis the Dynavision board
which tests pure reaction time your job
is to hit the
when it lights up right okay it's gonna
move pretty quickly okay so you're gonna
want to rely on your periphery okay I
can use either hand right you can use it
oh this is going to be a mess I can
already tell now Matt's calm and he's
making it look easy but this is way way
harder than it looks
[Music]
yeah there you go I just heard a whole
test damn it I'm gonna walk you over
tonight okay yes let's leave this far
behind yeah I'll see you in hell dine
aboard the next one test what's called
in cognitive processing under love it's
also a reaction test but unlike the
Dynavision board there's a voice telling
you to do the opposite of what you're
actually supposed to do okay there's
going to be a voice in your headset now
this is not my brain yeah it's tiring
right so was the brains crazy the last
test measures your ability to track
multiple objects at the same time we had
to keep tabs on certain spheres as they
floated around in a 3d space kind of
like trying to win two games of
three-card Monte at the same time for
seven three in five six and eight I got
better at it I feel like he does them no
they bounced off each other no moment of
truth let's see how I did hope you got
some good news for me where's always
these tests are built to really push
your cognitive processing but but at the
same time give you measurable results
and and immediate feedback Matt
outperformed you in the more complex
tasks so as tasks got more complicated
and had a significant amount of
distractions and opportunity for the
brain to start thinking about something
that wasn't primary to the task he
outperformed you pretty significantly at
those tasks if we were to compare both
your scores to a normal population of
which we have data he's in the 98th
percentile and you're probably the 60 or
70 percentile so are we talking about
self selection here is it that people
who are good at this stuff are playing
or is there proof that games can
actually improve your cognition in that
way no I think for sure games can help
improve your cognition playing video
games can be very high speed can create
a lot of chaos create a lot of multiple
environments where you have to make
decisions and all of these are forming
skills in the brain so no I think in
general just like in every capacity of
human performance we all start with some
baseline based on genetics but the
opportunity to train cognition I think
is really powerful ok so a pro gamer
who's 20 years younger than me beat me
at a few cognitive tests I mean of
course he did but what does science have
to say about all this video games is a
hugely broad category and we know for
sure that the impact of a game has to do
with what you're asked to do so because
of that different games will have
different impacts on on the brain you
know you wouldn't ask what's the impact
of food on your body you don't to know
the composition of the food right and so
the same is true of video games so you
know depending on what we would call the
mechanics the dynamics content of
individual games that is what would
predict how the games will affect your
brain action games like counter-strike
overwatch and Fortnight are some of the
most popular with consumers these days
and Greene and his colleagues look the
games like those to find out what their
impact is there are a subtype of games
action games that have been linked with
positive effects and perceptual and
cognitive skills these are games that
have lots of fast motion in them lots of
objects to track simultaneously an
emphasis on peripheral processing so
items first come at the edges of the
screen the need to make quick and
accurate decisions under time pressure
based on 15 years worth of studies
researchers have found that action games
biggest positive effects were on
perception how our senses interpret
external stimuli like sights and sounds
spatial cognition which helps you orient
yourself in and navigate 3d environments
and top-down attention the ability to
focus on one object while ignoring
distractions how far that generalizes I
think is a pretty open question so my
expectation is that there are plenty of
people who show pretty exceptional anti
coordination
with the joists that might not be able
to catch a baseball very well right and
so it's certainly the case that in a
perceptual motor skill development in
one area won't necessarily generalize to
all areas I'm curious about thoughts
that you have about the thresholds
between benefits gained from action
games and where those diminishing
returns might kick in you will get more
learning gained from smaller sessions
spread out over time than one big block
with respect to perceptual and cognitive
skills we've either seen a positive
impact or a null impact we haven't seen
any area that has been damaged where
there is worse performance so those are
the positive effects of playing action
games but what if you could develop
games that specifically harness those
cognitive effects that's exactly what
researchers are attempting and UCSF
neuro scape lab our goal is to bridge
technology and neuroscience to improve
the function of your brain the reason we
focus on cognitive control is because we
look at it as a very sort of base of the
pyramid that all other aspects of
cognition like memory or reasoning
decision-making all the way up to things
like wisdom are dependent upon it if you
can't pay attention everything from us
right you can't build any of the higher
order cognitive abilities they're custom
designing games that could one day be
prescribed as a kind of digital medicine
for patients with conditions like ADHD
so where pharmaceutical medicines
deliver molecular treatments we think of
this medicine as a digital medicine that
delivers experiential treatments the
videogame is essentially like our pill
they hooked me up with an EEG cap so
that I could see my brain activity in
real-time while playing a steering game
called project evoke responding to it
and there are signs so that game is now
in the FDA approval process to become
the first-ever subscribable video game
what we have frequently found is that
we're able to get transfer of benefits
from gameplay to other aspects of
attention that are very different than
the game neuro scape is also experiment
with virtual reality because VR can
utilize your whole body as a controller
and may well be able to compound the
benefits for things like attention and
memory a lot of data has shown that
physical activity even devoid of
cognitive challenges has positive
benefits on your brain especially the
aging brain so we asked the question
what happens if you give physical
challenges that are integrated with
cognitive challenge and create a sort of
integrated approach will you have even
more cognitive benefits if you're moving
your entire body bodied challenges as
opposed to playing that same game just
sitting there just moving your fingers
and we're testing that right now now
despite your findings and despite the
fact that you've been able to replicate
this you're in Phase three trials there
doesn't seem to be consensus in the
medical community there are a lot of
other scientists who say well no I mean
any any positives that you can derive
from games are kind of mild and
transitory at best how do you respond to
that it's a complicated field than it's
still early days I'm at least cautiously
optimistic based on what we've seen over
the last ten years that we're really on
to something that's going to be very
positive of people using video games and
therapeutic and if these games are
prescribed one day to improve brain
function there are still questions about
what the dosage should be it is
important to make it fun but it is also
critical to think of it as something
that's dosed and played for a limited
time and not interfering with the other
important activities in your life okay
now for the bad news
avid gaming can lead to injuries I see
many people have repetitive motion
injuries from gaming extensively you
know many gamers will gain from 8 to 16
hours a day six or seven days a week so
my goal when I'm talking to them find
out how much they game which games that
they're playing and what are their
injuries so the injuries are the
following often finger injuries wrist
injuries elbow injuries shoulder
injuries neck injuries
it's the wide gamut of the human body
really dr. Harrison also sees something
he calls gamers thumb and this is an
issue whereby someone will have
tendonitis the back of their thumb as
well as on the volar aspect of palmar
aspect of the thumb so they'll have pain
the back of the thumb in the front now
that I've only seen what gamers when
they present with that
they have really abused their bodies
their thumbs are really on fire when
this bad boy is down then you got a
problem
so I'm here I'm your patient yes P I
don't have big problems yet but I want
to prevent problems let me show you like
yeah let's say five basic stretches so
you're gonna go down and then bring your
fingers up you feel that I'm gonna
loosen up your joints as well as for
your wrists just to start opening up
everything and you get everything moving
really nice in and out with the thumb
right then down this is one of the
fundamental stretches that every gamers
should do council base keyboard base
Mouse whatever that is if you want to
have a healthy thumb you do them for
five to ten minutes twice a day not
difficult I think video games are are
great moderation is the key if you
overdo it there are always issues that
will be attached to that look there's no
question the gaming can wear you out
some gamers of the Sports Academy even
subject themselves to cryotherapy after
long sessions the jury's still out on
its effectiveness but some players swear
by it so I decided to give it a try all
right so there's freezing cold gas it's
dry go through this for two
two-and-a-half three minutes when you
come out which I can only hope is going
to be sometime sometime soon when you
come out and your body starts to warm up
again your blood that starts to
recirculate and it goes back out your
extremities so what have we learned here
other than the fact that I'm a masochist
gaming can be good for your hand-eye
coordination and perception it can help
with the focus attention maybe even
memory just how all that translates into
the real world still up for debate we
also know the repetitive gaming can take
a toll on your body so a little bit of
moderation goes a long way when it comes
to my own experience I've played games
for more than thirty years never
suffered any gaming related injuries
while I may never know of gaming helped
my brain I dunno it didn't
destroy it so take that mom